mariage adoption filiation les étudiants
réunis au sein de l'unef à l'université
de saint quentin en yvelines sont pour
ils le font savoir
dimanche 27 janvier ils participeront à
la manifestation parisienne pour
affirmer leurs voeux d'égalité pour tous
le mariage pour tous ici complètement
favorable parce que je pense que ça
réduit pas du tout la valeur d'un
mariage hétéro qu' il y ait des mariages
homos je suis favorable à l'adoption en
fait parce que je pense que dans
l'absolu un gamin qui vit dans un
orphelinat y sera moins qu il est vrai
qu'avec un gamin c'est un gamin qui vit
avec deux parents qui veulent donner les
meilleurs soit parce qu'on est on n'est
pas forcément dans la norme
hétérosexuelle qu'on peut pas avoir les
mêmes droits que justement ces gens là
même au niveau civique campagne de
sensibilisation sur les divers sites de
l'université puis tractage afin de
rassembler le plus de monde possible
c'est assez important que
neuf d'imposition totale de 1000 f
puisque c'est le seul cortège bas jeunes
et donc bah ça on trouvera que plus il y
aura de monde aux cortèges la pousse un
droit que les jeunes sont invités s'ils
entendent les mouvements de protestation
des manifestations précédentes
leur point de vue est imparable je
respecte tout à fait la pensée
catholique comme je respecte toute autre
religion
mais je pense que les arguments qui
justement sont basées sur la religion
aujourd'hui n'ont absolument pas leur
place dans ce débat puisque nous sommes
dans un état laïc et que bien voilà les
lois n'ont pas être régi par une
quelconque autorité divine mais bien par
la loi dimanche prochain un départ
commun est prévu lui lagarde versailles
chantiers à 12h30 pour aller tous
ensemble à paris défendre le droit à
l'égalité pour tous